in the meantime the 2020 presidential
election was predicted to be close
and it is votes are still being counted
in several key states right now
and it may be days before we know who
will be the next president
skyler henry has the latest for us from
the white house joe biden's campaign
team
says they are confident the democratic
nominee has won the election
joe biden is on track to win this
election
and he will be the next president of the
united states
the trump campaign is already saying it
will file an immediate recount as soon
as wisconsin has called for biden
and we've had a recount before and it
showed that we have a really good
process
we have a really good system biden
pulled ahead this morning in wisconsin
and michigan
as more votes were counted those states
combined with nevada and arizona where
he also leads would be enough to push
him above the 270 electoral votes needed
to win
president trump has taken to twitter to
claim without any evidence
of wrongdoing that his lead has
magically disappeared in democrat-run
states
the president tweeted that they're
working hard to make the 500 000 vote
advantage in pennsylvania disappear
asap likewise in michigan and others
last night the president called on the
vote counting to stop while he still had
an early lead
we'll be going to the u.s supreme court
we want all voting to stop
biden's camp says they have lawyers on
standby to fight any attempt to not
count legal votes
skyler henry cbs news the white house
and just a short time ago the trump
campaign announced it will file a
lawsuit in michigan
to stop the count there because it says
it has been denied
access to numerous counting locations so
we'll keep an eye on that